لم أتوقع أبدًا أي شيء مثل ذلك
جوناثان
شاربنتير في الصف الثامن هو أحدث
مكتشف للديناصورات لمتحف الطبيعة والعلوم في دنفر
،
لذلك التقطته
ولكن لم يكن لدي أي دليل على أنه سيكون أحد
أسنان الديناصورات ،
فقد وجد هذا الديناصور ريكس
أثناء التنزه في مقاطعة جنوب شرق بولدر ،
لم أستطع تصديق ذلك في البداية ، اعتقدت
أنه
لا توجد طريقة حقًا يمكن أن يكون شيئًا
مثيرًا للاهتمام ،
لكن شيئًا شعرت أنه قلته جيدًا ،
أرسل بريدًا إلكترونيًا إلى المتحف ومعرفة ما إذا كان
بإمكانهم قول أي شيء  حول هذا الموضوع
ثم تم دمج هذا مع
جمجمة جوناثان الذي قام بتحويل السن إلى
أمين الديناصور جو
سيرتيك يقول إن كولورادو هي منطقة رئيسية
لتي ريكس استنادًا إلى المنطقة التي
خرجت فيها هذه السن
وهو ما نسميه تشكيل اللارامي
الذي يقع بين حوالي  68 مليون و
68.5 مليون سنة ، لذلك مضى حوالي
مليوني ونصف سنة قبل
انقراض الديناصورات ، لذلك هذا هو
أحد آخر الديناصورات التي عاشت هنا في
كولورادو
جوناث  يعني اكتشاف an حفرًا أكبر
لمزيد من
عظام الديناصورات ، فمن المحتمل أن
يبدأ الكثير من الأبحاث الجديدة ، لذلك
سنعود إلى هذه المنطقة
ربما مع جوناثان
وسنجمع المزيد من العظام ونأمل أن يكون هناك
المزيد من  يوجد t-rex في الخارج في انتظار
أن
نحفره الآن جزء من تاريخ كولورادو المتعثر لدى
جوناثان بعض النصائح للأشخاص الآخرين
الذين
يحبون الخروج في الهواء الطلق ، ابحث عن
هذه الأشياء
لأنك حقًا يمكنك العثور عليها في أي مكان